du rififi dans le monde aéronautique
français la cfdt syndicat d'air inter
s'inquiète dans un communiqué de l'opéra
offre publique d'achat in amicale lancée
par le pdg d'air france contre air inter
avec le concours de la sncf
fin de citation la cfdt redoute qu'air
france ne prenne le contrôle d'air inter
qu'en est il de cette brouille qui met
en scène trois entreprises publiques
eve mettait air inter sera t-elle
filiale d'air france en fait l'idée
n'est pas nouvelle
depuis plusieurs mois on sait que le
gouvernement souhaite une réorganisation
du paysage aérien français en vue du
grand marché de 1992 selon la cfdt d'air
inter les cartes seraient prêts air
france qui détient aujourd'hui 36% du
capital d'air inter s'apprêterait à
gonfler sa participation à 48% en
achetant les parts de la compagnie
intérieure détenue par la sncf il
suffirait alors air france de grappiller
quelques titres auprès d'autres
actionnaires pour s'assurer la majorité
du capital
les conséquences sont de deux ordres
d'abord des conséquences pour les
consommateurs de transport est rien
puisque vous savez lire interparti des
tarifs sont proches de la moitié de ceux
d'air france et que donc cette prise de
parts cette prise de direction vers
inter par air france conduirait à
changement en la matière donc une
augmentation des tarifs est rien et
surtout nous prenions le démantèlement
notre entreprise et air france
souhaiterait la déporter à roissy et
avec les économies d'échelle supprimé
des milliers d'emplois dans notre
entreprise à la direction des deux
compagnies aériennes ainsi qu'au
ministère des transports on refuse de
confirmer l'information
l'ensemble des syndicats d'air inter se
réunira jeudi pour définir d'éventuelles
mode d'action
mais la cfdt précise que si une grève
était envisagée afin de ne pas causer de
dommages aux vacanciers aucun mouvement
ne serait déclenché avant le mois de
septembre